hi I'm in the dressing room at the
Palace Theatre in Louisville Kentucky on
June 14th 2018 and I thought I'd read
you an excerpt from maps of meaning the
architecture of belief which is a book I
published in 99 with Routledge and it's
been the basis of my YouTube lectures
and I would say also twelve rules for
life a lot of the ideas and twelve rules
for life were first worked out with maps
of meaning I just recorded an audio
version of the book was released two
days ago June 12 2008 een and it's
available from Penguin Books on audible
I'll put the links in the description of
the video I'm hoping that the audio
version with its careful intonation will
be easier to understand maps of meaning
is a rather difficult book in any case
I'm going to read you an excerpt from it
today and that'll serve as a bit of an
introduction to the book I'll make some
more excerpts over the next coming weeks
I think as well but we'll start with
this one I was reading Jeffrey Burton
Russell's mephistopheles the devil in
the modern world when I came across his
discussion of Dostoyevsky's The Brothers
Karamazov Russell discusses Ivan's
argument for atheism which is one of the
most powerful ever mounted Ivan is one
of the brothers in The Brothers
Karamazov
Ivan's examples of evil all taken from
the daily newspapers of 1876 are
unforgettable the nobleman who orders
his hounds to tear the peasant boy to
pieces in front of his mother the man
who whips his struggling horse on its
gentle eyes the parents who locked their
tiny daughter all night in the freezing
privy while she knocks on the walls
pleading for mercy the Turk who
entertains a baby with a shiny pistol
before blowing its brains out
Ivan knows that such horrors of kur
daily and can be multiplied without end
I took the case of children Ivan
explains to make
case clearer of the other tears with
which the earth is soaked I will say
nothing Burton Russell states the
relation of evil to God has in the
century of Auschwitz and Hiroshima once
again become center of philosophical and
theological discussion the problem of
evil can be stated simply God is
omnipotent God is perfectly good such a
God would not permit evil to exist but
we observe that evil exists therefore
God does not exist variations on this
theme are nearly infinite the problem is
not only abstract and philosophical of
course it is also personal and immediate
believers tend to forget that their God
takes away everything that one cares
about possessions comforts success
professional craft knowledge friends
family and life what kind of God is this
any decent religion must face this
question squarely and no answer is
credible that cannot be given in the
face of dying children it seems to me
that we use the horrors of the world to
justify our own inadequacies we make the
presumption that human vulnerability is
a sufficient cause of human cruelty we
blame God and God's creation for
twisting and perverting our souls and
claim all the time to be innocent
victims of circumstance what do you say
to a dying child you say you can do it
there is something in you that is strong
enough to do it and you don't use the
terrible vulnerability of children as an
excuse for the rejection of existence
and the perpetration of conscious evil
when I wrote maps of meaning I did not
have much experience as a clinical
psychologist two of my patients however
stayed in my mind the first was a woman
about 35 years old she looked 50 she
reminded me of a medieval peasant of my
conception of a medieval peasant she was
dirty clothes hair teeth dirty with the
kind of Filth that takes months to
develop she was unbearably shy she
approached anyone who she thought was
superior in status to her which was
virtually everyone hunched over with her
eyes shaded by her hands both hands as
if she could not tolerate the light
emanating from her target she had been
in behavioral treatment in a Montreal
hospital before as an outpatient and was
in fact a sight known to the permanent
staff at the clinic others had tried to
help her overcome her unfortunate manner
of self presentation which made people
on the streets shy away from her made
them regard her as crazy and
unpredictable she could learn to stand
or sit up temporarily with eyes on
garden but she reverted to her old
habits as soon as she left the clinic
she may have been intellectually
impaired in consequence of some
biological fault it was difficult to
tell because her environment was so
appalling it may have caused her
ignorant she was illiterate
as well she lived with her mother whose
character I knew nothing about and with
an elderly desperately ill bedridden
aunt her boyfriend was a violent
alcoholic schizophrenic who mistreated
her psychologically and physically who
was always muddling her simple mind with
tirades about the devil and the worship
of Satan she had nothing going for her
no beauty no intelligence no loving
family no skills no employment nothing
she didn't come to therapy to resolve
her problems however nor to unburden her
soul nor to describe her mistreatment
and victimization at the hands of others
she came she came because she wanted to
do something for someone who was worse
off than her of the clinic where I was
interning was associated with a large
psychiatric hospital all of the patients
that still remained after the shift to
community
CAIR in the aftermath of the 60s were so
incapacitated that they could not
survive on the streets she had done some
volunteer work of some limited type in
that hospital and decided if she could
maybe befriend a patient take him or her
outside for a walk I think she got this
idea because she had a dog which he
walked regularly and what she liked to
take care of all she wanted from me was
help arranging this helped finding
someone who she could take outside help
finding someone in the hospital
bureaucracy who would allow this to
happen I was not very successful in
aiding her but she didn't seem to hold
that against me it is said that one
piece of evidence that runs contrary to
a theory is sufficient to disprove that
theory of course people do not think
this way and perhaps should not in
general a theory is too useful to give
up easily too difficult to regenerate
and the evidence against should be
consistent and believable before it is
accepted but the existence of this woman
made me think she was destined for a
psychopathological end from the
viewpoint of biological and
environmental determinism fated as
surely as anyone I had ever met and
maybe she beat her dog sometimes and was
rude to her sick aunt maybe I never saw
her vindictive or unpleasant even when
her simple wishes were thwarted I don't
want to say that she was a saint
because I didn't know her well enough to
tell but the fact was that in her misery
and simplicity she remained without self
pity and able to see outside of herself
why wasn't she a criminal cruel
unbalanced and miserable she had every
reason to be and yet she wasn't in her
simple way she had made the proper
choices she remained bloody but unbowed
and she seemed to me rightly or wrongly
to be a symbol of suffering humanity
sorely afflicted yet capable of cur
and love God justifies his creation in
Milton's Paradise Lost such I created
all the ethereal powers and spirits both
them who stood and them who failed not
free what proof could they have given
sincere of true allegiance constant
faith or love where only what they needs
must do appeared not what they would
what praise could they receive what
pleasure I from such obedience paid when
will and reason reason also his choice
useless and vain of freedom both de
spoiled made passive both had served
necessity not me they therefore as to
right belonged so were created nor can
justly accuse their maker or their
making or their fate as if
predestination overruled their will
disposed by absolute decree or high
foreknowledge they themselves decreed
their own revolt not I if I for new
foreknowledge have no influence on their
fault which had no less proved certain
unfair known so without least impulse or
shadow of fate or ought by me immutably
foreseen they trespass authors to
themselves in all both what they judge
and what they choose for so I formed
them free and free they must remain till
they enthralled themselves I else must
change their nature and revoke the high
decree unchangeable eternal which
ordained their freedom they themselves
ordained their fall the other patient I
wish to describe was the schizophrenic
in a small inpatient ward at a different
Hospital he was about 29 when I met him
a few years older than I was at the time
and had been in and out of confinement
for seven years he was of course on
antipsychotic medication and
participated in occupational therapy Act
he's on the ward making coasters and
pencil holders and so on but he could
not maintain attention for any amount of
time it was not even much good at crafts
my supervisor asked me to administer an
intelligence test to him the standard
ways are more for the sake of my
experience than for any possible
diagnostic good I gave my patients some
of the red and white blocks that made up
the block design sub tests he was
supposed to arrange the blocks so they
matched a pattern printed on some cards
he picked them up and started to
rearrange them on the desk in front of
him while I timed him stupidly with a
stopwatch the task was impossible for
him even at the simplest of stages
he looked constantly distracted and
frustrated I asked what's wrong
he said the battle between good and evil
in heaven is going on in my head I
stopped the testing at that point I
didn't know exactly what to make of his
comment
he was obviously suffering and the
testing seemed to make it worse what was
he experiencing he wasn't lying that's
for sure in the face of such a statement
it seemed ridiculous to continue I spent
some time with him that summer I never
met someone who was so blatantly
mentally ill we talked on the ward and
occasionally I would take him for a walk
through the hospital grounds outside he
was the third son of first generation
immigrants his firstborn brother was a
lawyer the other a physician his parents
were obviously ambitious for their
children hard-working and disciplined he
had been a graduate student working
towards a degree in immunology I don't
precisely remember his brothers had sent
him a daunting example and he felt
pressured to succeed his experimental
work had not turned out as he had
expected however and he apparently came
to believe that he might not graduate
not at least when he had hoped to so
he faked his experimental results and
wrote up his thesis anyway he told me
that the night he finished writing he
woke up and saw the devil standing over
him at the foot of his bed this event
triggered the onset of his mental
illness from which he had never
recovered it might be said that the
satanic apparition merely accompanied
the expression of some pathological
stress induced neural development whose
appearance was biologically
predetermined or that the devil was
merely personification of his cultures
conception of moral evil manifesting
itself in imagination as a consequence
of his guilt
both of these levels of description have
their merits but the fact remains that
he saw the devil and at the vision
accompanied or even was the event that
destroyed him he was afraid to tell me
much of his fantasy and it was only
after I had paid careful attention to
him that he opened up he was not
bragging or trying to impress me he was
terrified about what he believed
terrified as a consequence of the
fantasies that impressed themselves upon
him he told me that he could not leave
the hospital because someone was waiting
to shoot him a typical paranoid delusion
why did someone want to kill him well he
was hospitalized during the Cold War not
at its height perhaps but still during a
time when the threat of purposeful
nuclear annihilation seemed more
plausible more likely than it does now
many of the people I knew used the
existence of this threat to justify to
themselves their failure to participate
fully in life a life which they thought
of romantically as doomed and therefore
as pointless but there was some real
terror in the pose and the thought of
the countless missiles pointed here and
there around the world sapped the energy
and faith of everyone hypocritical or
not my schizophrenic patient believed
that he was in fact the incarnation of
the world annihilating force that he was
destined
is released from the hospital to make
his way south to a nuclear missile silo
on American territory that he was fated
to make the decision that would launch
the final war the people outside the
hospital knew this and that is why they
were waiting to shoot him he did not
want to tell me this story in
consequence although he did because he
thought that I might then want to kill
him too my friends in graduate school
thought of ironic that I had contact
with a patient of this type my peculiar
interest in young and Young's ideas
regarding the collective unconscious
were well known to them and it seemed
absurdly fitting that I would end up
talking to someone with delusions of
this title but I didn't know what to do
with his ideas of course they were crazy
and they had done in my patient but it
still seemed to me that they were true
from the metaphorical viewpoint his
story in totality linked his individual
choice between good and evil with the
cumulative horror then facing the world
his story implied that because he had
given in to temptation at a critical
juncture he was in fact responsible for
the horror of the potential of nuclear
war but how could this be and seemed
insane to me to even consider that the
act of one powerless individual could be
linked in some manner to the outcome of
history as a whole but I have no longer
so sure I've read much about evil and
its manner of perpetration and growth
and I'm no longer convinced that each of
us are so innocent so harmless it is of
course a logical to presume that one
person one speck of dust among six
billion motes is any sense responsible
for the horrible course of human events
but that course in itself is not logical
far from it and it seems likely that it
depends on processes that we do not
understand the most powerful arguments
for the non-existence of God at least a
good God are predicated on the idea that
such a being would not allow for the
resistance of evil in its classical
natural diseases disasters or moral war
pogroms forms such arguments can be
taken further even than atheism can be
used to dispute the justice of the
existent world itself
Dostoyevsky states perhaps the entire
cosmos is not worth a single innocent
child's suffering how can the universe
be constructed such that pain is
permitted
how can a good God allow for the
existence of a suffering world these
difficult questions can be addressed in
part as a consequence of careful
analysis of evil first it seems
reasonable to insist upon the value of
the natural / moral distinction the
tragic circumstances of life should not
be placed in the same category as
willfully undertaken harm tragedy
subjugation to the mortal conditions of
existence has an ennobling aspect at
least in potential and has been
constantly exploited to that end in
great literature and mythology true evil
by contrast is anything but noble
participation it Out's whose sole
purpose is expansion of innocent pain
and suffering destroys character
forthright encounter with tragedy by
contrast may increase it this is the
meaning of the christian myth of the
crucifixion it is christ's full
participation in and freely chosen
acceptance of his fate which he shares
with all mankind that enables him to
manifest his full identity with god
and it is that identity which enables
him to bear that fate and which strips
it of evil conversely it is the
voluntary demeaning of our own
characters which makes the necessary
tragic conditions of existence appear
evil but why is life tragic why are we
subject to unbearable limitation to pain
zees and death to cruelty at the hands
of nature and society
why do terrible things happen to
everyone these are of course
unanswerable questions but they must be
answered somehow if we are able to face
our own lives the best I can make of it
is this this has helped me nothing can
exist without preconditions
even a game cannot be played without
rules and the rules say what cannot be
done as much as what can perhaps the
world is not possible as a world without
its borders without its rules
maybe existence wouldn't be possible in
the absence of our painful limitations
think of it this way if we could have
everything we wanted merely for wishing
it if every tool performed every job if
all men were omniscient and immortal
that everything would be the same the
same all-powerful thing God and creation
would never exist that is the
differences between things which is a
function of their specific limitations
that allows them to exist at all but the
fact that things do exist does not mean
that they should exist even if we are
willing to grant them their necessary
limitations should the world exist are
the preconditions of experience so
terrible that the whole game should be
called off and there is never any
shortage of people working diligently
towards this end it seems to me that we
answer this question implicitly but
profoundly when we lose someone we loved
and then grieve this is a very common
experience I don't think we cried
because they existed either but because
they are lost this presupposes a
judgment rendered at a very fundamental
level of analysis grief presupposes
having loved presupposes the judgment
that this person's specific bounded
exists
was valuable was something that should
have been even in its inevitably
imperfect and vulnerable form but still
the question lingers why should things
even love things exist at all
if they're necessary limitations cause
such suffering perhaps we could reserve
answer to the question of God's nature
his responsibility for the presence of
the evil in creation until we have
solved the problem of our own
perhaps we could tolerate the horrors of
the world if we left our own characters
intact and developed them to the fullest
if we took full advantage of every gift
we had been granted perhaps the world
would not look horrible then that was
from pages 343 to 347 from maps of
meaning published in 1999 audio version
released June 12 2018 I'll read some
more excerpts in the coming days and
weeks thanks very much bye bye